my favorite scent we see all the wars
bred border and in zombies people says I
enjoy know everything he cook in South
Italy this in Chaves you like anchovies
come on Pizza anchovies my name is
roberto Petula I'm do my return on it
was found in the Bronx
my name is cherub Ferrara I'm the chef
at zero turnover in the Bronx I grew up
in Salerno I used to go with my father
in this popular restaurant then I used
to smell the pizza they used to make the
fresh tomato and basil and the smell of
this pizzeria when the left woman that
was 17 years old I create exactly the
same pizza in Riyadh everybody knows to
Pizza Napoletana because first pizza was
made in Naples I enable the pizza they
make a little bit more soft you know in
Salinas a little more crunchy we used
the same England flour water mozzarella
and tomato but just to make the pizza
insulin a little bit more crispy
[Music]
you know it can make so many different
Pizza My dear aging a pizza called Pizza
Margherita just told me that's a pizza
where you make a motivator from
salerno's with mozzarella tomato basil
and olive oil cooked in 803 oven though
it's done
every morning we make the mix the mix is
only four ingredients it's flour water
salt and a little bit of yeast it's
mixed slowly and then it's let it
ferment outside for 24 hours one of the
big differences between American pizza
and Italian pizza is American pizzas you
take a strip from the refrigerator
some pizza has to be room temperature
cause if you cook it it's too dense
won't get crisp it'll be soggy doesn't
work our pizzas made on the table it's
very important for us to have even pizza
when it cooks so we stretch it out to
about 10 inches we put a little bit of
sauce we put the basil first we put the
mozzarella on top of the basil because
if you don't the basil burned the
mozzarella we get it's actually day-old
material that we get from Arad so it's a
positive element said if it's fresh it's
too watery and when it melts in the
pizza it'll destroy the pizza it has to
be allowed to drain and dry in the
refrigerator before it's able to be used
we put a little bit of olive oil on top
into the oven not even 90 seconds later
it's done we are exactly the same
Ivan we using some ethanol and we use
wood it's made to be heated in the
morning use it throughout the day you
actually look inside the oven the oven
is domed the flame is not only going up
but it's going around so when you're
cooking the pizza you actually have to
keep on moving and put it towards the
ceiling of the oven if you don't it
doesn't cook typical pizza from Solano
is the marinara it's a tomato sauce
anchovies capers and basil a little bit
of fresh oil it sounds simple but it's
very good it has a lot of depth and
Charlie's Kapus is so good we get
brilliant obviously in fact 1100 the
meat and fish and all my produce
everything is far today
everything actually this should make me
the mayor act 11 yeah I spent so much
money at 11 I grew up in a family 11
kids six broad and five system em my
house back home was a restaurant every
day you know my father was a good chef
he cook and every day as soon as you
finish eating everything was good today
what we gonna eat tomorrow that's the
way I grew up and you know it's amazing
when you leave up UConn she want you
young and you bring back the smell and
the taste of food back home always stays
with you I'm in the kitchen I cooked I
still reminds me the same smell my
mother my father is the cooker
justperson food
symbol whatever I cook I cook only what
I like tea and that's what we do in your
bathtub and Sarah
you